qué repercusiones tendrán estas medidas
anunciadas por el gobierno israelí
Hola Valentina Muy buenas tardes por
allá en Francia muy buenos días por acá
en América Latina saludos a todos pues
definitivamente la repercusiones que
tendrán en la población Palestina
principalmente pues va a ser el
recrudecimiento de las condiciones en
las cuales han vivido en los últimos 50
años no en realidad el gobierno de
tanyahu desde que llegó en esta ocasión
nuevamente al poder su línea política su
su marco de acción político era muy
claro en continuar la expansión de los
asentamientos en territorio palestino y
seguir limitando Pues de manera abrupta
no las condiciones de vida de de los
millones de palestinos que viven en
cisjordania principalmente y en casa
también definitivamente una reciente
encuesta realizada por grupos de
investigación tanto de los palestinos
como de una universidad desde la vi
revela que el apoyo a la propuesta de
los dos estados para solucionar el
conflicto nunca había tenido tampoco
respaldo en la historia como en este
momento a qué se debe
definitivamente ha habido un intento no
sobre todo de las élites políticas
israelíes de
legitimizar de acabar de agotar la
solución de los dos estados
no Israel y Palestina entonces la
población sobre toda la población joven
en Israel cada vez ve con menos ojos
positivos no el derecho a existir de del
estado palestino como tal a pesar de
todos los movimientos y y buenos actos
políticos que hubo sobre todo a finales
de la década de los noventas principios
de de los dos miles después de la
segunda intinfada que
del año 2000 definitivamente esta vía
esta opción ha tenido cada vez menos
repercusión e insisto las las nuevas
generaciones ven con menos ojos esta
posibilidad y siquiera interesados en
que exista esta posibilidad misma que
que se concrete no bueno y la misma
encuesta señala justamente que ambas
partes creen que existe un riesgo alto
de que se produzca una tercera intifada
esto es posible
Pues en realidad es algo que se ha
estado digamos que de cierta manera
gestando no el malestar dentro de la
población Palestina a la que se ha
llevado insisto Prácticamente todo este
siglo no es decir ha estado presente
desde la creación de los dos de la
canción del estado de Israel pero en los
últimos
20 años no ha sido cada vez más fuerte y
en los últimos años creo que ha sido más
exacerbada definitivamente el programa
político que presentó el gobierno que se
ha conformado encabezado por
esta ocasión es mucho más agresivo y
impositivo hacia la comunidad Palestina
no entonces las las posibilidades las
Mentes de de un enfrentamiento mucho
mayor de respuesta de los grupos armados
y de los grupos políticos palestinos
pues no debería de ser
agenda no donde habría no debe ser algo
que nos tome por sorpresa
definitivamente bueno y algo que se está
poniendo en duda Discúlpeme algo que se
está poniendo en duda es si las
decisiones radicales que está tomando el
gobierno realmente son del Primer
Ministro o si esta es una cuestión de
presión qué se puede decir al respecto
pues
desafortunadamente hemos visto que el
actuar del Primer Ministro en todos
estos años que ha estado no ya es el
Primer Ministro con con más longevidad
que ha tenido este Cargo en sus
diferentes etapas que ha tenido ha sido
bastante consistente No definitivamente
obedece también a los grupos a los
cuales se se va a liar en este caso en
el gobierno actual es un gobierno
probablemente el más conservador
ultranacionalista que va a tener Y
definitivamente su línea va a ser mucho
más radical y mucho más fuerte que los
gobiernos anteriores Pero eso no quiere
decir que en los gobiernos anteriores no
fueron incrementándose estas condiciones
no el número de asentamientos
israelíes en todo el territorio
palestino a lo largo de los gobiernos de
netanyahu ha crecido de manera
exponencial el año pasado a pesar de que
el gobierno israelí estaba en manos de
Yahir la pip no vimos Cómo se reprodu
con las condiciones a los padres sino no
fue el año más sangriento en Palestina
entonces seguramente iremos en ese esa
misma línea